we expect opening statements later today
in steve bannon's criminal trial he's
the former chief political strategist
for former president trump and he is
accused two counts of contempt of
congress after he rejected a subpoena
from the house january 6 committee and
he's been claiming executive privilege
scott mcfarland is covering that federal
trial it's in washington where jury
selection began yesterday and he's not
far from where the capital riot occurred
scott good morning
good morning steve bannon's legal team
sought to delay this trial arguing the
january six committee hearings would
bias the jury but we begin this day with
nearly two dozen prospective jurors that
both sides deemed acceptable they'll
finish selection this morning likely
moved to opening statements this morning
the prospective jurors all lived here in
the nation's capital some told the judge
they never heard of steve bannon some
say they have watched the january 6
committee hearings but that it wouldn't
impact their ability to render a fair
verdict but the big question is when or
if will steve bannon take the stand here
in his own defense
in the meantime the u.s secret service
today is expected to hand over text
messages to the january 6 committee
subpoenaed from january 5th and january
6 2021 an internal watchdog had warned
those messages were deleted but vlad
today the committee will likely find out
how many messages survived or were
retrieved
all right scott thank you very much